bonjour à tous j'ai très heureux d'être
ici alors j'ai cinq ans je regarde un
championnat d'athlétisme à la télé et je
dis à mon père je sais pas pas plus tard
je ferai les jeux olympiques mon père se
lève va dans la cuisine et la suite je
vous la raconterai un petit peu plus
tard alors je m'appelle arnaud assoumani
je suis né le 4 septembre 1985 d'une
mère blanche française et d'un père
black d'origine comorienne
je suis ce que l'homme peut faire de
mieux un métis
j'ai une soeur et un frère on n'en
partage pas la même mère et j'ai une
petite particularité c'est que je suis
né sans avant-bras gauche
alors mes parents j'imagine en tant que
parent on est un petit peu peur
justement de son fils qui a handicapé
qui va grandir dans une société pas
forcément évidente et donc du coup il me
pousse à la natation
ils sont très sportifs eux-mêmes mon
père a fait 25 ans de basket
ma mère a fait le même temps de
volley-ball et donc je suis bébés
nageurs
j'ai deux ans et je vais faire de la
natation pour encore 12 autres années
donc de barboter au début après je
commence à réellement nagé à nager de
plus en plus vite et faire des
compétitions bas jusqu'à un niveau
interrégional embrasse sur tout et je me
rappelle de ma première compétition
c'était sur la droite c'était aux ulis
et je suis sur la dernière longueur
tous les compétiteurs sont déjà arrivés
et moi j'entends encore mais les
encouragements et je suis en train de
couler et en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que j'ai pas du tout abandonnée je
me suis dit voilà faut finir la course
quoi faut aller jusqu'au bout
et donc j'ai découvert à ce moment là
déjà la persévérance est ce que voulait
dire un petit peu le dépassement de soi
alors ça c'est pas mes dessins je
dessine beaucoup mieux que ça non alors
comme chaque enfant en fait j'ai appris
à lire l'heure j'ai aussi appris à faire
du vélo mais pour moi c'était un petit
peu différent parce que pour mettre une
monde par exemple tout seul il faut que
j'ai d'abord une petite technique quoi
donc chaque montre à son système de
fermeture et pas au départ bon là je
pars pas d'aujourd'hui c'est un bon
exemple mais je vais mettre 20 minutes
pour la m
et puis on va me dire tu veux que je te
dise
il faut que j'arrive tout seul et puis
au bout de dix fois je vais m peut-être
30 secondes quoi pour le vélo c'est un
petit peu pareil au début j'étais sans
prothèse donc vous imaginez vous êtes un
petit peu déséquilibré comme ça faut
faire un petit peu attention au menton
et je me dis je découvre il faut que je
m'adapte que mon corps qu'on pense
vraiment super bien et ça c'est des
qualités qui vont qui vont me suivre un
petit peu plus tard alors juste avant
vous revenir là dessus parce que j'ai
pas fini
je suis un passionné de sport donc je
fais de la natation mais je fais jusqu'à
trois sports en même temps de basket
tennis de table et puis je pouvais faire
un match de foot avec les amis entre
temps mais ce que je voulais réellement
faire c'était l'athlétisme et donc mes
parents divorcent malheureusement je me
retrouve à vivre seule avec ma mère du
côté d'angers à rochefort sur loire dans
un village je suis le seul black avec un
handicap
donc voilà c'est une changement de vie
puisque j'avais je suis né et j'ai
grandi en région parisienne et donc il
m'autorise à 12 ans à faire de
l'athlétisme parce qu'avant il pensait
que c'était trop traumatisant et donc là
bas je suis super content en fait parce
que bon je touche à toucher avec les
potes on s'amusait tout mais je suis bon
en fait dans la discipline que j'aime
c'est à dire le château de sable le saut
en longueur ou s'il veut pas très bien
quand même
et donc bah voila je progresse quoi et
surtout je m'amuse donc de champion
départemental
je suis sûre champion régional après
champions inter régional et en 2002 je
raccroche définitivement la natation et
je me dis bon maintenant je me consacre
exclusivement à l'athlétisme parce que
voilà j'adore ça quoi et donc la même
année je participe pour la première fois
aux championnats de france jeunes à
angers et je termine dans les dix
meilleurs français
alors avec mon entraîneur de l'époque
gail gonzalez on se dit mais peut-être
que ton niveau est intéressant par
rapport à là où on dit sport
paralympique alors moi
connaissais rien du tout ce que je
voulais faire c'était de l'athlétisme je
voulais pas forcément faire de
l'athlétisme avec des gens qui me
ressemblent à des gens j'avais pas de
dredd à l'époque mais avec des gens
métis ou avec quelqu'un carrément avant
bras en moins par exemple donc on va au
championnat de france
et là en fait on se rend compte que le
niveau que j'avais en valide m'amener
déjà dans les trois meilleurs mondiaux
et de là je fais ma première sélection
en 2003 pour les championnats d'europe
où je remporte trois médailles deux d'or
on accepte est juste énorme pour moi
mais surtout je découvre réellement un
nouveau monde
le monde paralympique est également le
monde avec des personnes qui ont un
handicap et je crois que j'ai jamais eu
autant de plaisir en fait à être avec
des gens je me suis jamais autant amusé
il ya une dérision folle on se chambre
énormément et surtout en fait on voit
déjà aussi des personnes avec des routes
ya beaucoup plus lourd des personnes qui
sont amputé des quatre membres ou autres
et au départ ben moi c'est pas forcément
évident et moi je me suis jamais
considéré handicapés et puisque le mans
compte c'est que heu c'est exactement la
même chose quoi sont jamais considérés
handicapés et c'est assez marrant parce
qu'en fait à ce moment là je me suis en
fait ça me renvoie à mon propre handicap
mais voilà j'avais 17 ans je me levais
tous les matins et donc je me voyais
bien dans le miroir j'ai eu aussi des
moqueries au collège ou à des moments ça
pas été forcément évident voilà ça me
renvoyer mon handicap
l'année d'après ma première sélection je
participe aux jeux paralympiques
d'athènes donc jeux paralympiques pour
moi c'était juste monstrueux j'ai à
peine 19 ans et bat cérémonie
d'ouverture
70000 spectateurs on est comme ça dans
le couloir juste avant de rentrer et
voilà on a les yeux qui brillent
c'est vraiment c'était vraiment
hallucinant et donc je décroche une
médaille de bronze pour ma première
participation avec 6 mètre 91
sur le moment je suis déçu en fait parce
que je venais de faire cette mettrons
cette année là et donc je me dis
moi c'est pas terrible sauf qu'au final
c'est quand même pas mal mais je
découvre aussi ce dont beaucoup de
sportifs sont pas victimes mais vivent
avec la blessure et donc je vais avoir
pendant trois autres années j'ai une
blessure au dos on sait pas réellement
ce que c'est donc je vais rechercher
mais c'est une période où je vais devoir
justement faire un travail et aussi
mental je n'avais pas de coach mental à
ce moment là mais je devais avoir un
équilibre en tout cas donc je vous ai
pas parlé des études mais la priorité
pour mes parents a été toujours les
études de le dire dans tous les cas
c'est pas le sport qui te fera vivre
donc fois vous faudra bien travailler
quoi donc j'ai eu un cursus assez
classique j'ai fait un bac scientifique
après je suis arrivé à paris j'ai
poursuivi des études dans l'audiovisuel
chez monteur vidéo de formation et j'ai
découvert la créativité d'ailleurs
j'étais créatif ce que mes qualités que
je ne pensais pas avoir et un peu plus
tard également j'intègre une formation à
sciences po
la première promotion pour les sportifs
de haut niveau et il ya un autre
équilibre que j'ai et que j'adore c'est
la musique alors la musique vraiment la
seule chose qui fait que je suis voilà
j'étais un peu dégoûté entre guillemets
qui manque un bras c'était de ne pas
pouvoir jouer d'instruments quoi je peux
pas vraiment joué le piano à la rigueur
à une main je faisais un peu la guitare
c'était compliqué même si je vous
quelques trucs de nirvana les autres
mais surtout j'ai découvert à 15 ans le
beatbox en fait donc le beatbox sais pas
si vous connaissez mais c'est la musique
avec la bouche comme ça par exemple
marié à quand donc voilà et la musique
je découvre aussi par mon cousin clément
la batucada donc le samba est un
instrument percussif qui s'appelle le
répit ni qui ressemble comme vous voyez
à une grosse caisse claire et ça se joue
en fait avec une baguette et la main et
quand je vois cet instrument au carnaval
tropical de paris jeudi
waouh c'est excellent je suis sûr que je
peux jouer de cet instrument la cua donc
du coup je commence une école de samba
et mon objectif était de au bout d'un an
de rejoindre son bateau qui était à
l'époque en fait le meilleur groupe sur
paris il faut entre 2 et 3 ans
normalement pour y arriver
donc je me dis bon allez je vais
travailler dur et puis j'espère que ça
va le faire quoi au bout d'un mois de
débutant je passe à avancer personne qui
joue depuis un ou deux ans et au bout de
trois mois à ma plus grande surprise
j'ai le mestré da bateria le chef
d'orchestre qui me dit ça te dirait pas
de venir jouer avec samba touques jeudi
bat karé ment c'est énorme
donc du coup je vais été joué avec eux
et au bout de neuf mois pour la fête de
la musique on a décidé d'organiser voilà
la fête de la musique la place d'aligre
à paris et je me suis dit je pense que
je peux diriger j'ai jamais fait mais
bon je vais apprendre un peu et puis ça
devrait le faire
et en fait on s'est entraîné pendant
trois mois et le résultat était juste
était juste monstrueux donc en cette
année là et pendant cette période où
justement je suis en train de nous
reconstruire mentalement je me
reconstruis également physiquement je
pas compris je toujours pas compris
pourquoi j'avais des soucis au niveau du
dos mais j'ai accepté ses soucis là j'ai
fait le maximum que je pouvais faire
justement pour mais vivre avec et puis
je soulager la douleur
j'intègre un groupe professionnel à
l'époque c'était avec le team lagardère
et je m'entraîne avec guy ontanon qui
est qui est le meilleur entraîneur de
sprint français est à partir de ce
moment là je repars un petit peu d'une
feuille blanche en fait je me dis j'ai
pas de limites
j'ai plus de records et surtout j'ai en
ligne de mire pékin et remporter la
médaille d'or donc à pékin
après toutes ces années de galère et
tout va bien
mais au bout du deuxième essai je fais
cette m 23
je bats le record du monde à l'époque et
je décroche cette médaille d'or
voilà qui était un peu inespéré pendant
ces quatre ans où j'avais quasiment
arrêté j'avais quasiment arrêté
l'athlétisme
c'était juste dingue parce que le nid
d'oiseau comme vous pouvez le voir était
archicomble y avait 90 milles aux
spectateurs bon les gens connaissaient
pas tellement l'athlétisme en l'état
avec il faut que les soupes les stades
sont remplies qu'importe l'ambiance
était quand même folle pour moi et ils
ont quand même dû me virer après mon
tour d'honneur parce que je resté trop
longtemps quand je vois t'es sympa le
français là mais bon à partir de ce
moment là et cette médaille d'or il ya
vraiment eu un déclic lorsque j'étais
sur le podium la marseillaise alors il y
avait un petit manque
c'était ma famille ma famille ne pouvait
malheureusement pas être présentes ni
les amis mais ce rêve justement que
j'avais en moi de vouloir participer aux
jeux olympiques qui est vraiment un rêve
d'enfant s'est progressivement
transformée en fête et je me fixe à ce
moment là l'objectif de participer aux
jeux olympiques et aux jeux
paralympiques
ce qui à ce moment-là ce régime est
toujours enfin ça s'est jamais fait au
niveau français et au niveau
international
oscar pistorius l'a fait en 2012 donc
pour vous situer je vous ai 17 m 23
records du monde à ce moment là pour se
qualifier à londres il faut que je saute
huit médecins donc ça fait 1 m un petit
peu moins 97 cm pareil et c'est
réellement un monde en saut en longueur
mais je suis confiant et je dois vous
avouer quelque chose d'ailleurs à ce
propos et enfin ça j'en ai jamais parlé
réellement c'est que depuis tout petit
j'ai une croyance parle beaucoup de
religions c'est que quel que soit mon
objectif et quel que soit ce que je veux
faire plus tard je me dis que quoi qu'il
arrive j'y arriverai je ne sais pas d'où
ça vient peut-être le fait que j'ai dû
m'adapter toute ma vie par rapport à
voile à cette petite particularité
toujours est il que
voilà je sais que c'est possible et que
je vais y être quoi donc
entre 2009 et 2010 je connais ma plus
grande progression de 7 mètres 23 jeux
bad de multiples fois le record du monde
pour sauter 7 mètres 75 à la fin 2009
et je souhaite 7 mètres 80 de l'année
d'après à bercy aux championnats de
france élite valide j'aime pas dire
valides et handisports comme sais pas je
suis spécialiste de son coeur et pas de
handicap et je termine sur la médaille
sur pardon je termine sur la troisième
marche du podium
et pour moi c'est assez énorme parce que
badge une symboliquement ses formes pour
voilà géré assez génial le premier
athlète avec un handicap etc
mais surtout je montre que les gars
faudra compter sur moi je serai là dans
deux ans et en 2012
alors l'année d'après en 2011 je
progresse encore
je saute à 7 m 91 avec un petit peu trop
devant je mords pour la première fois
des sauts à plus de 8 m lui-même dit su
mettre 15 peut-être mais toujours est-il
ces mordus
alors juste pour voilà vous dire le saut
en longueur il ya une course d'élan on
saute mais une petite contrainte c'est
la planche il faut pas mort il ya une
plastiscines et donc malheureusement bas
des fois je me rendais de cm des fois un
peu plus tôt mais pas trop y penser
c'est un petit peu dur est donc en 2012
en fait j'ai l'idée de lancer un
concours qui s'appelle golden armes et
qui est pour customiser mon mât
prothèses de course de compétition en
parallèle j'ai fait des recherches avec
des biomécanicien pour améliorer mon
équilibre justement par rapport à cette
prothèse je me dis ouais ça peut être
super cool quand même aussi
voilà elle a un aspect un peu fun et le
thème c'est super héros donc vous pouvez
faire un peu ce que vous voulez si vous
voulez vous pouvez faire un truc un peu
à la tron où est donc pour moi c'est
vraiment passer le message que voilà on
est le handicap là on l'attend pas
forcément c'est à dire dans un milieu
créatif est positif et également dire
que moi en fait les prothèses s'écoule
coire où il ya des choses que vous
pouvez pas faire par exemple du baseball
avec votre bras ou masse et vos potes un
peu mal au dos ou également se séparer
d'elle lorsqu'elle vous énerve
je vois que certains messieurs là sont
bien faire s'attendre en 2012 donc je
veux briser des barrières et en même
temps j'ai une grosse pression
médiatique
j'ai des sponsors qui me permette de
vivre et de m'entraîner dans les
meilleures conditions
je commence à avoir des problèmes avec
mon entraîneur avec qui ça se passait
très bien on a une mauvaise relation et
en même temps ben voila je reconnais des
blessures c'est pas la situation idéale
et à dix jours des championnats de
france je me blesse gravement au tendon
d'achille je sais pas encore ce que j'ai
mais les championnats sont à angers
c'est mon objectif
donc voilà je sais pertinemment que je
vais y arriver je dis c'est pas un
tendon qui va faire que
ça va mal se passer et donc à angers dès
l'échauffement j'ai mal et je me dis bon
allez accroche toi ça va le faire
et sur la piste lorsque voilà je suis en
train d' impulser avant de le concours
démarre je ressens une énorme douleur
comme si on me plantait une aiguille
dans le mollet et danton d'achille et là
je comprends que ça va pas être possible
quoi et là c'est super dur je craque en
fait parce que ben c'est le stade de mes
débuts
et puis surtout il ya mes grands parents
qui sont dans le stade et à ma famille
et donc voilà je voulais en tout cas
sauter devant eux même si je me
qualifiais pas à ce moment là c'est pas
terminé en fait parce qu'il ya encore
les jeux paralympiques derrière et je
fais une médaille voire deux médailles à
aller chercher en individuel en saut en
longueur et en triple saut en triple
saut je me suis entraîné réellement deux
mois sur les 4 ans et plus pour le fun
entre guillemets je passe tout près de
la correctionnelle parce que sur le
cinquième essai lors des jeux je ne me
fait mal à la cheville et sur le dernier
essai j'arrive à je sais pas comment me
déchirer et je remporte une médaille
d'argent donc à londres vous voyez j'ai
le sourire à gauche
avec cette médaille d'argent et le
lendemain deux jours plus tard pardon je
retrouve le même chinois qui mal battu
pour le triple saut en saut en longueur
et donc là je sais que ça va pas être la
même chose du tout parce que il est sur
mon terrain avec tout ce que j'ai vécu
c'est pas possible que tu gagnes sauf
que le chinois ils sautent 7 m 15
je commence le concours à moins de 7
mètres quelques jours avant les
championnats
j'avais sauté à 7 mètres 50 et je
m'étais dit bah je suis revenu à mon
meilleur niveau et lâche lui un peu
perdue je comprends pas et en fait je
suis de nouveau dans le rouge
je suis fatigué et une pro pour la
première fois de ma carrière je dois
avancer les foules et doit être plus
près de la planche parce que j'arrive
fatigué quoi donc de 19 foulée qui est
mon élan complet je passe à 15 foulée
puis à 13 foulée et donc je saute 7 m
0,6 sur le quatrième essai je me dis
allez allez tu peux le faire quoi rester
à voile et 13,2 et s'est fait le coin et
sur le dernier essai tout le monde se
lève dans les tribunes et crois que j'ai
gagné et en fait je réalise 7 m 12
je suis troisième quoi donc pour moi à
ce moment-là ça ton un petit peu comme
un couperet comme un deuxième échec
vraiment difficile à avaler
sauf qu'en réalité ce n'était pas le
c'était pas le plus difficile pour moi
ce que tu es plus difficile c'était que
j'étais devant ma famille et que je
voulais rendre fiers et pour moi ça
passait par une médaille d'or sauf qu'en
réalité ce n'était pas vraiment ça le
plus important
j'ai mon nom qui est venu me voir et qui
m'a dit merci merci' harnes
j'ai une question raconte jean de faire
deuxième merci pourquoi il me dit merci
parce que dit m moi ça fait quinze ans
que j'ai pas vu ton père que j'ai pas vu
ta soeur et grâce à toi nos deux
familles sont réunis et c'est là que
j'ai compris que voilà en fait tout le
monde était fier de moi et puis il y
avait que moi qui était réellement
triste est que c'était pas c'était
vraiment pas laissant l'essentiel
le point positif par rapport au jeu et
qui dépasse en tant que personne et que
mes objectifs c'est que j'ai été élu au
conseil des athlètes au sein du comité
international paralympique donc pour
représenter avec neuf autres collègues
tous les athlètes du monde entier
donc ça c'est une réelle fierté est en
fait réellement quelque chose qui a du
sens pas pour soi même et pour les
autres
après tous ces événements et ses quatre
ans de dur travail je prends des
vacances et je vais pour la première
fois aux comores avec mon cousin
mon frère
et puis je découvre je suis accueilli
comme un héros national et je découvre
un pays incroyable de tolérance et je
comprends un petit peu mieux d'où vient
mon métissage déjà parce que c'est un
pays qui est très très métissée et on
vit des choses exceptionnelles je crois
pas vraiment vous en parler là je
pourrais vous en parler pendant des
heures mais maintenant voilà pourquoi
d'autres est-ce que je continue oui je
continue bien sûr j'ai pas réussi c'est
un échec mais j'apprends de mon échec et
le but pour moi voilà c'est de me
tourner vers rio 2016 j'ai toujours le
même objectif
est-ce que je vais réussir j'en sais
rien par contre je pars sur la route
pour de nouveaux connaissais pas ça
c'est des voitures automatiques faille
tu peux dormir et tous c'est mieux que
la google car
et donc je m'envole vers les etats unis
vers des meilleures conditions
d'entraînement je m'entraîne au centre
olympique à shula vista avec ce groupe
un peu réalisé voilà vous pouvez voir le
cadre est pas trop mal et je m'entraîne
parmi les meilleurs athlètes du monde
will claye pour ceux qui connaissent
double médaillé olympique longueur et
triple triple saut brittney reese la
seule femme à avoir remporté trois fois
championnats du monde en saut en
longueur et qui est championne olympique
et je suis le seul en fait athlète a pas
avoir réussi à sauter vie m enfin le
loser est donc aujourd'hui je continue
en fait à garder ce personnage pour
faire vivre un petit peu mon aventure
américaine à mes proches et à ceux qui
me suivent et ceux qui le veulent
ça s'appelle golden armes avec golden
vespa donc la prothèse créé par thomas
hourdin le gagnant du concours et je
fais ça sous forme de petits épisodes
j'essaye de d'utiliser mes compétences
de monteur ce que j'aime la musique et
c'est pour avoir un truc assez rythmé
assez punchy
voilà pour faire vivre l'athlétisme pas
que pourra juste parce que c'est que la
vie sportive de haut niveau est un peu
loin des clichés qu'on peut qu'on peut
qu'on peut avoir
j'ai cinq ans regarde un championnat
d'athlétisme à la télé et lorsque je dis
à mon père plus tard je ferais je ne
m'implique papa il part dans la cuisine
est donc la suite que je vais vous
raconter m'a été racontée par mon tuteur
de sciences po mon père assez pudique
du monde peu ses émotions et aussi la
personne la plus optimiste que je
connaisse me l'aurait jamais dit quoi
en fait il est parti dans la cuisine
pour pleurer ici
il s'est dit parce que mon fils un
handicap
ce sera pas possible en réalité toute ma
vie j'ai voilà une des compétences comme
chacun d'entre vous avec vos expériences
et ses qualités pour l'instant je les
mets au service du sport c'est assez
personnelle assez égoïste on va dire
mais le but c'est justement de pouvoir
utiliser ses qualités ses compétences
développées aussi au service des autres
et pour pouvoir redonner et duran duran
tous ces moments là ce qui est le plus
important en fait c'est que le rêve
emmène bien au delà de même notre simple
rêve sans qu'on l'ait forcément touchés
j'ai fait des rencontres exceptionnelles
durant pardon j'ai fait des rencontres
exceptionnelles durant ma carrière qui
n'est pas terminée je rencontre des gens
incroyables aujourd'hui et ces personnes
là qui était en argentine
si on a un accident tragique elle
pourrait être à ma place pour voir
raconter leur parcours très fort
également et qui pourrait vous inspirer
je suis simplement un sportif de haut
niveau je pourrais être quelqu'un
d'autre qui vous raconte mon parcours
et voilà si je peux vous éclairer la
seule chose que j'ai à dire c'est que la
différence est une force et que nos
différences peuvent nous amener au delà
du possible
merci beaucoup